[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend hinein am Tag danach in Hamburg
die Mutter hat überlebt ihr 28 Wochen
altes ungeborenes Kind im Leib wurde
durch die Schüsse getötet das ist nur
ein Teil der amokat von gestern Abend
die überall in Deutschland so
fassungslos macht da erschießt jemand
sieben Menschen in einem Gemeindehaus
der Zeugen Jehovas und anschließend sich
selbst acht weitere Menschen werden zum
Teil schwer verletzt wie kann ein Mensch
zu so etwas fähig sein und wie konnte
das passieren Fragen am Tag danach aus
Hamburg Martin Niessen
Kerzen anzünden Blumen ablegen
ohnmächtige Gesten der Menschen nach
einer weiteren brutalen und sinnlosen
Blut hat und dann kommt die Politik
beklagt Opfer wenn enthelden so auch
heute in Hamburg eine waffente
Amokläufer hat sieben Menschen
erschossen
und weitere Personen schwer verletzt
nur das schnelle Eingreifen der Polizei
konnte
den Mord weiterer Personen verhindern im
Licht des Tages zeigte sich der ganze
Horror der vergangenen Nacht Bestatter
transportierten die Leichen aus dem
Gebetshaus der Zeugen Jehovas in Hamburg
Alsterdorf ab am Abend zuvor hatte ein
ehemaliges Gemeindemitglied zunächst vor
dem Gebäude das Feuer eröffnet danach
hat der Täter mit der Schusswaffe durch
die Scheibe auf die Veranstaltung
eingewirkt ist im weiteren Verlauf durch
das Fenster in das Gebäude eingedrungen
und der permanenten Schusswaffengebrauch
durch Notrufe alarmiert und zufällig in
der Nähe stürmten spezialkräfte der
Polizei nur wenige Minuten später das
Haus brachten acht Verletzte und etwa 20
weitere Gottesdienst Besucher in
Sicherheit im ersten Stock finden sie
die Leiche des mutmaßlichen Täters und
die Tatwaffe für die besaß Philipp F
eine gültige Waffen besitzkarte erst im
Januar war der 35-Jährige von der
Polizei nach einem anonymen Hinweis
überprüft worden ein hinweisschreiben
von einer bis heute unbekannten Person
mit mein Ziel dieses Ziel ist in dem
Schreiben zum Ausdruck gebracht das
Verhalten und die waffenrechtlichen
Vorschriften in Bezug auf den Philipp F
zu überprüfen eine Überprüfung ohne
größere Beanstandungen nach der Tat
stellte die Staatsanwaltschaft in seiner
Wohnung allerdings mehrere hundert
schussmunition sicher als Motiv vermuten
die Ermittler private Gründe bei Philipp
F handelt es sich um ein ehemaliges
Mitglied dieser Gemeinde der Zeugen
Jehovas welches die Gemeinde vor etwa
anderthalb Jahren freiwillig aber
offenbar nicht im guten verlassen hat
Experten gelten die Zeugen Jehovas als
repressiv gegenüber Menschen die die
Gemeinde verlassen es gibt leider genug
ehemalige Mitglieder die geächtet werden
und die das als ein starken seelischen
Stress empfinden und meine erste
Vermutung ist natürlich auch dass er
enttäuscht ist dass er wütend gewesen
ist
und dass er immer perfekt dann zu so
einer Schre cklichen Tat gekommen ist
dagegen spricht die große Menge Munition
die Philipp F gehortet hatte und da
kommt wieder die Politik ins Spiel die
bundesinnenministerin will die
Waffengesetze verschärfen das ist mir
ein wichtiges Anliegen weil wir durch
die furchtbaren Taten in Halle Hanau ähm
ja schon gesehen haben dass es
Handlungsbedarf gibt den Menschen in
Hamburg bleiben derweil nur Gesten wie
das Anzünden von Kerzen und das Ablegen
von Blumen
in Karlsruhe ist heute Abend eine
Geiselnahme wohl glimpflich zu Ende
gegangen ein Mann hatte in einer
Apotheke dort mehrere Menschen über
Stunden in seiner Gewalt die Polizei hat
die Apotheke vor einer halben Stunde
gestürmt der Täter ist überwältigt es
wurde wohl niemand verletzt
unser nächstes Thema aus dem Land der
Reformation kommt heute eine Lautstärke
bitte an den Papst in Rom sie kommt von
der eigenen römisch-katholischen Kirche
von Laien und Klerikern die gemeinsam
einen neuen sogenannten Synodalen Weg
gehen wollen unter dem Eindruck von
missbrauchskandalen und massenaustritten
das Zeichen in Richtung Vatikan hätte
nach Meinung vieler eine Forderung sein
müssen aber die deutschen Bischöfe
konnten sich maximal aufbitten einigen
bitte um Reform so will die katholische
Kirche in Deutschland Segens Feiern für
homosexuelle Paare offiziell zulassen
ich spreche gleich mit dem Vorsitzenden
der Deutschen Bischofskonferenz über die
Reaktion des Papstes ersticken Klinge
über das was da aus Deutschland Richtung
Peters Platz halt
immer wieder muss beraten werden immer
wieder ist die Spannung im Raum spürbar
etwa als es um die Frage geht ob Frauen
künftig eine größere Rolle in der
katholischen Kirche spielen sollen der
Text geht durch mit Kompromissen
predigen wird erlaubt Taufen oder die
Beichte Abnehmen nicht da hält sich die
Begeisterung bei vielen in Grenzen
[Applaus]
mir fehlt konkret dass wir sehr bewusst
sagen dass Frauen allen Rechte haben
sollen die Männer in der Kirche auch
haben als Ordensfrau und auch Leiterin
einer geistlichen Gemeinschaft weiß ich
wie schwierig das manchmal ist gerade in
der in der Sakramentenspendung wenn eben
sterbende Kranke sich das Sakrament der
Versöhnung wünschen dass wir eben nicht
tätig werden können deutlich zügiger
fällt die Entscheidung dass Segens
Feiern für homosexuelle Paare künftig
erlaubt sind die Erleichterung ist groß
bereits gestern wurde ein Text
beschlossen in dem der Papst um die
Prüfung des Pflicht zu leibats gebeten
wird nach drei Jahren Beratung geht es
voran auf dem Synodalen Weg dem
Reformprozess der katholischen Kirche
aber in kleinen Schritten
der aus meiner Sicht aus unserer Sicht
sind die Bischöfe jetzt dran sich zu
bewegen wir haben gezeigt dass wir zu
Kompromissen bereit sind für einzelne
sicher bis an die Schmerzgrenze auch
wenn die meisten der Bischöfe
reformwillig sind einige konservative
lehnen viele der geplanten Neuerungen ab
mit Spannung erwartet wird zum Beispiel
noch wie mit dem Thema geschlechtliche
Vielfalt umgegangen werden soll für mich
persönlich als katholischer Mensch der
Theologie studiert hat der
transident ist und in Beziehung lebt ist
natürlich sind all diese Themen extrem
relevant und wichtig Rom beobachtet den
deutschen Weg durch den Botschafter des
Vatikans denunzius sehr genau und hat
mehrfach nein gesagt zu zentralen
Reformvorhaben Bischof Bode der in der
Arbeitsgruppe zur Position der Frauen
mitgearbeitet hat bleibt trotzdem
optimistisch
was die Sakramente etwa angeht die die
Weihe von Frau und zu Diakoninnen und
zur zu Priestern das ist natürlich etwas
was der schon in Rom auch in
Kommissionen bedacht wird und wenn wir
jetzt noch mal dem als Bischofskonferenz
ein Schub geben hat es natürlich schon
seine Wirkung man will nicht ausscheren
heißt es immer wieder aber dennoch
vorangehen
ist sicherlich gegen den Widerstand des
Rom zu beschließen man segnet ab sofort
gleich geschlechtliche Partnerschaften
da gab es vor wenigen Wochen erst noch
ein Schreiben wo die Römer ist verboten
haben das zeigt er Selbstbewusstsein der
deutschen Kirche das zeigt es selbst so
musst du Bewusstsein dieser Synodalen
und das ist gut so der Synodale Weg geht
auch nach dem morgigen Tag weiter in
kleineren Gruppen ob es gegen den Willen
von Rom ein Gremium geben wird in dem
Bischöfe und Laien gemeinsam
Entscheidungen treffen können ist noch
offen
der Limburger Bischof georg betzing ist
Vorsitzender der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz und jetzt live bei uns
in der Sendung guten Abend
guten Abend was sagt denn der Papst zu
ihren Reformen Ideen haben Sie schon
eine Reaktion
nein natürlich nicht wir sitzen hier
mitten in den Beratungen und sind
zunächst einmal sehr dankbar und froh
und auch ein bisschen geschafft dass wir
so viel miteinander auf den Weg bringen
konnten aber es kommt ja jetzt darauf an
was der Papst am Ende mit all dem macht
ob er ihnen das alles erlaubt wann
fahren sie denn nach oben sie hatten ja
vorher angekündigt dahin fahren zu
wollen und mittelbar nach dem Synodalen
weg
ja zunächst muss man ja wieder sagen wir
haben ganz viele Dinge die wir hier in
unserem Land umsetzen können und werden
weil es dem Recht entspricht das ganze
Arbeitsrecht ist verändert worden wir
haben heute beschlossen wir werden Paare
die nicht kirchlich verheiratet sind
kirchlich sie segnen also homosexuelle
Paare Paare die geschieden und wieder
verheiratet sind Paare die um den Segen
bitten das ist etwas was wir hier tun ja
das können sie hier tun aber das Problem
ist dass der Vatikan dazu bisher immer
gesagt hat es sei nicht erlaubt
homosexuelle Partnerschaften zu segnen
heißt das sie setzen sich jetzt quasi
über den Papst hinweg
zunächst einmal muss man sagen die
Praxis der Segnung gibt es und wir
wollen sie ans Licht holen und das heißt
dass wir Bischöfe uns dazu positionieren
und sagen es ist gut dass wir das tun
was in einer Beziehung zwischen zwei
Menschen in der Partnerschaft gut ist
das kann auch den Segen Gottes bekommen
das ist nur folgerichtig und wir haben
heute gehört aus der belgischen Kirche
dass dies dort auch schon umgesetzt ist
und dass das sogar mit Strom bereits
besprochen ist ja ihr Kollege aus
Belgien hat gesagt er habe das so quasi
so nebenbei irgendwie durchgekriegt aber
ist denn das wirklich das was Sie wollen
nämlich wie sie gerade gesagt haben es
ans Licht holen weil es gut ist sind sie
ganz sicher dass der Papst das ganz
genau so sieht
wir werden es hier umsetzen wir haben
dazu ganz intensiv gearbeitet wir haben
ja in vier Foren gearbeitet mit sich
Personen aus dem Synodalen Weg mit
Expertinnen und Experten haben solide
Texte erstellt in denen die
Argumentationen die zu unserem
Beschlüssen führen ja sehr ausführlich
dargelegt sind und darüber sind wir
gerne bereit zu sprechen aber das
Handeln wird verändert werden das ist ja
durchaus eine Ansage wenn ich das so
höre ehrlich gesagt auch eine Ansage von
ihnen jetzt aus Deutschland Richtung
Vatikan deshalb Herr Bischof noch mal
die Frage wann fahren sie denn nach oben
wann hören sie denn dann tatsächlich die
Reaktion
ja also das ist mit dem fahren nach Rom
ja nicht getan wir werden nach der
fünften synodalversammlung alle
Beschlüsse wir haben ja über 10
Beschlüsse gefasst die das Handeln der
Kirche in Deutschland sehr stark
verändern werden wir werden das alles
zusammenstellen sichten und dann die
Fragen die mit Rom zu besprechen sind
dort bilateral in die jeweiligen Kanäle
geben es ist ja nicht so dass ich
einfach als sozusagen mit dem Rucksack
als Vorsitzender zum papstfahrer und
sage hier hast du jetzt alles sondern
wir haben ja gesetzte Gesprächskanäle
und auch Möglichkeiten wie wir dort ins
Gespräch kommen und das werden wir tun
und nicht nur ich allein wir wollen ja
gerne auch mit dem synodal Präsidium das
habe ich zuletzt noch einmal in einem
Brief sehr deutlich nach oben
signalisiert wir möchten mit dem ganzen
Präsidium das heißt auch mit Präsidentin
und viel zu Präsident des ZDK des
Zentralkomitee ist nach Rom kommen um
dort Gesicht zu zeigen und
Gespräch zu gehen die Frage ist aber wie
viel einheitliches Gesicht können die
deutschen Bischöfe tatsächlich zeigen
denn sie hätten sie haben ja schon eine
ja eine schwierige Rolle sage ich jetzt
mal den einen den Gläubigen geht das
nicht weit genug was sie da beschließen
und dann gibt es Hardliner in den
eigenen Reihen ihre Kollegen als
Bischöfe die sagen das geht mir viel zu
weit und die du nur darauf warten so
scheint es zumindest dass sie beim Papst
scheitern mit dem was sie vorhaben
ja zumindest haben wir und das ist gut
im Statut des Synodalen Weges geregelt
es braucht eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit
der Bischöfe auch der Bischöfe um
Entscheidungen zu beschließen und für
all das was wir jetzt auf dem Synodalen
Weg miteinander entschieden haben haben
wir zwei Drittel und mehr der Bischöfe
ich glaube damit kann man sich schon
zeigen und auch nach Rom gehen also sie
vertrauen da sozusagen auf die
Mehrheitsentscheidung was sagen sie denn
zum Beispiel zu jemandem wie Erzbischof
genzwein dem Privatsekretär dem
ehemaligen Privatsekretär von das im
irritierten Papstes Benedikt der hat
heute gesagt er macht sich ernsthafte
Sorgen dass sich die römische
katholische Kirche in Deutschland aus
der Einheit der Weltkirche verabschiedet
sehen sie auch die Einheit der Kirche
tatsächlich jetzt in Gefahr
das ist ein mediothekel was immer wieder
beschworen wird und ich habe es vor
kurzem gesagt und bleibe auch dabei wer
von Spaltung spricht der verspricht sich
vielleicht etwas davon wir sprechen
nicht davon wir wollen sie nicht und
werden in der Einheit mit der großen
katholischen Kirche der Welt bleiben
dann sind wir gespannt darauf was sie
tatsächlich in Rom erreichen beim Papst
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch heute
Abend bei uns Bischof Betzingen heute
schon mal
sehr gerne
und wir gucken hier auf weitere Themen
des Tages und die hast du im Blick
Hannah ja da schauen wir zuerst auf
China denn Staats- und Parteichef skijin
Ping bleibt für weitere fünf Jahre
Präsident der Volksrepublik die fast
3.000 Delegierten das Volkskongresses
bestätigten seine dritte Amtszeit
erwartungsgemäß einstimmig der Schritt
ist historisch da Ski eigens dafür die
Verfassung ändern ließ ursprünglich war
die Regierungszeit auf 10 Jahre begrenzt
Ski wurde außerdem als Oberbefehlshaber
der Streitkräfte Chinas bestätigt
[Applaus]
um die illegale Zuwanderung über den
Ärmelkanal zu begrenzen will
Großbritannien in den kommenden drei
Jahren 540 Millionen Euro an Frankreich
zahlen das erklärte der britische
Premier sunack nach Gesprächen mit dem
französischen Präsidenten
macronisepalast zugleich beschworen
macron und zunak einen politischen
Neubeginn und erklärten in Zukunft auch
in anderen Bereichen enger
zusammenarbeiten zu wollen etwa in der
Verteidigung der Ukraine sagten beide
erneut ihre Unterstützung zu
wir bleiben in Frankreich denn dort
wurden zwei weitere Risse an
Rohrleitungen in Atomkraftwerken
entdeckt betroffen sind das
kraftwerk-nom nah der deutschen Grenze
und erneut das AKW Poldi im Norden des
Landes wo bereits am Dienstag ein Riss
gemeldet worden war die Rohrleitungen
seien bereits ausgetauscht worden
erklärt eine Sprecherin der
Atomsicherheitsbehörde bei den beiden
neuen rissen handele es sich um
Abnutzungserscheinungen
in Georgien hat das Parlament nach
massiven Protesten das geplante
Mediengesetz in zweiter Lesung abgelehnt
viele Abgeordnete der Regierungspartei
die am Dienstag noch dafür gestimmt
hatten Leben der Sitzung fern mehrere
Tage gingen Tausende Georgier gegen den
Gesetzentwurf auf die Straße dieser sah
vor dass sich Medien und andere
Organisationen als ausländische Agenten
registrieren müssen wenn sie zu mehr als
20% aus dem Ausland finanziert werden
ein ähnliches Gesetz gibt es in Russland
so und dann eine Nachricht heute die um
die Welt geht weil sie enorme Folgen
haben kann für die Menschen in einer
viel geprüften Region
acht Jahre Krieg zwischen Iran und Irak
fast 1,4 Millionen Tote
die Kinder im Jemen Krieg in dem
hunderttausende getötet wurden
dasselbe im Grauen des Bürgerkrieges in
Syrien
alles angefacht und befeuert durch Iran
und Saudi-Arabien immer standen oder
stehen sich die beiden direkt oder im
Hintergrund gegenüber zwei Nächte in
einer Region die einander Spinne Feind
sind der mehrheitlich schiitische Iran
und das sunnitische Saudi-Arabien die
beiden Rivalen wollen jetzt einen großen
Schritt aufeinander zu machen es gibt
einen Deal zwischen beiden vermittelt
durch China dass seine neue Rolle
genießt es soll wieder die
problematische Beziehungen geben
Differenzen wie es offiziell heißt
sollen beigelegt werden Christian Kirsch
und Kamera
[Musik]
sie kämpfen um die Vormachtstellung in
der Region das Königreich Saudi-Arabien
und die Islamische Republik Iran
religiöse Gegensätze trennen beide
Staaten das sunnitische Saudi-Arabien
sieht sich als Hüter der heiligsten
Städten das Islam in Mekka und Medina
Iran hingegen ist das Kernland und die
Schutzmacht der Schiiten beide Staaten
sind seit Jahren fundamental verfeindet
und verfolgen zum Teil entgegengesetzte
politische Interessen so ist etwa
Saudi-Arabien strategischer Partner der
USA Iran betrachtet die US-Amerikaner
als totfeind
auch das Verhältnis zu Israel ist
grundsätzlich verschieden auch israel
sieht der Iran als totfeind
Saudi-Arabien hält zwar große Distanz zu
Israel allerdings gab es auch moderate
Annäherung im Krieg im Jemen
unterstützen beide Länder
unterschiedliche Kriegsparteien auch in
Syrien führen Iran und Saudi-Arabien
einen Stellvertreterkrieg Iran
außenpolitisch in der Region fast
isoliert sucht derzeit neue Partner in
Asien die überraschende Annäherung an
Saudi-Arabien wurde offenbar auch auf
Betreiben Chinas erreicht
innerhalb der nächsten zwei Monate
wollen beide starten nach sieben Jahren
wieder diplomatische Beziehungen
aufnehmen
der heute journal Überblick und drei
Fragen dazu jetzt noch an Daniel Gerlach
nahostexperte Chefredakteur des
Fachmagazins Zenit erkennt viele der
Akteure in der Region persönlich guten
Abend Herr Gerlach und gleich die erste
Frage was hat beide Seiten dazu gebracht
jetzt aufeinander zuzugehen schauen Sie
diese beiden Mächte haben über Jahre
eine Nullsummenspiel gespielt da ging es
immer darum ich kann nur gewinnen wenn
ich der anderen Seite schade und beide
haben Schaden davon getragen und ich
denke man sagt im Nahen Osten geht's
immer ums Überleben diese beiden Mächte
diese beiden Systeme kämpfen das
Überleben und sie sehen eben dass sie
keine internationalen schutzgerannten
haben die sich für sie einsetzen und das
gilt jetzt auch für Saudi-Arabien Iraner
haben sich immer alleine gefühlt aber
auch Saudi-Arabien sieht die Welt
polarisiert sich und die Amerikaner sind
nicht mehr die Macht die ihr Überleben
garantiert und deswegen nähert man sich
an die Frage ist natürlich diplomatische
Beziehungen sind ja der Anfang aber es
tun gerade viele so als seien jetzt
damit die Konflikte aus der Welt
geschafft und ein großer Frieden
geschlossen davon kann keine Rede sein
das immer noch entfernt aber was heißt
das jetzt für die Menschen in den beiden
Ländern den beiden direkt Beteiligten
und eben auch in all den Staaten der
Region in denen der Konflikt zwischen
diesen beiden Staaten für so viel Leid
gesorgt hat ja hoffen wir dass es den
Menschen besser geht Saudi-Arabien
versucht seit Jahren aus diesem
furchtbaren Krieg im Jemen irgendwie
gesichtswaren rauszukommen und hat aber
noch keine wirkliche Lösung gefunden und
natürlich kann es helfen wenn die Iraner
dort auch deeskalieren dieser im Beitrag
eben angesprochene Antagonismus zwischen
Sunniten und Schiiten der von beiden
Seiten ziemlich verantwortungslos auch
befeuert wurde der hat beiden Seiten
geschadet man sieht tatsächlich in der
Politik dass sie das Zurücknehmen zum
Beispiel hat Saudi Arabien Kleriker auch
bestraft und im kalt gestellt die
versucht haben gegen den cheismus zu
arretieren und auch in Iran Hoffmann
dass diese ringschätzung Missachtung von
der politischen Tradition die man aus
Iran immer wieder gehört hat etwas
runtergefahren wird aber wie gesagt die
Menschen können davon profitieren aber
ein Pakt für Frieden und Menschenrecht
ist das nicht was wir hier leben sondern
das sind ganz kalte Interessen wieder
abgewogen wurden macht Interessen Herr
Gerlach die dritte Frage noch welche
Folgen ergeben sich für den Westen also
welche Rolle spielen wir hier überhaupt
noch naja die westlichen Staaten finden
es okay und finden es gut dass ich diese
beiden Staaten annähern das hat mir auch
immer gefordert zumal die westlichen
Staaten nicht in der Lage sind den
nukleardeal von dem ja auch
Saudi-Arabien profitieren würde eben
durchzusetzen und das führt dazu die
westlichen Staaten ziehen sich
letztendlich mal weiter heraus
Deutschland Europa hat kaum noch
Einflussmöglichkeiten und Saudi-Arabien
positioniert sich anders als früher als
Mittelmacht zwischen China und den USA
und ist auch er hat auch Sympathien für
Russland und das ist eine neue
geopolitische Situation die eigentlich
zu einem Machtverlust des Westens in der
Region führt der aber nicht nur
schlechte Zeiten muss drei Fragen an
Daniel Gerlach chefrei dafür ist eine
Osten Magazins Zenit ganz herzlichen
Dank für diese Erläuterung danke schön
da Gerät also enorm etwas in Bewegung
und das gilt auch für unser nächstes
Thema bisschen sperriger Begriff in
flation reduction Act aber massive
Folgen massive wirtschaftliche Folgen
für uns alle es geht um das
Subventionsprogramm des US-Präsidenten
er will die unfassbare Summe von 369
Milliarden Dollar in Klimaschutz und
Energiesicherheit Pumpen allerdings
unter der strikten Auflage dass die
Produktion made in Amerika ist das saugt
gerade zu unternehmen Weg aus Europa
über den Atlantik ein Horror-Szenario
für die EU die amerikanische Politik sei
eine ernsthafte Gefahr für Europas
Industrie ob kommissionspräsidentin
Ursula von der Leyen da heute in
Washington bei Joe Biden noch etwas
ausrichten kann Florian neuhahn
berichtet
das Lächeln sitzt die Gesten auch im
Weißen Haus vor zwei Stunden nichts soll
wohl darauf hindeuten dass zwischen
diesen beiden irgendein konfliktbestünde
immer gut sie zu sehen sie leisten
hervorragende Arbeit wir sind nicht nur
Partner die EU und die USA sind gute
Freunde dabei haben die guten Freunde in
den Abgrund geschaut eines handelskriegs
sie kämpfen um die Schlüsselindustrie
der Zukunft gegeneinander und gegen
China es geht um Elektroautos darum wer
sie produziert und Europa fürchtet
diesen Kampf zu verlieren ein internes
Papier der EU-Kommission das dem ZDF
vorliegt warnt beinahe jedes vierte
Unternehmen erwege Jobs oder Produktion
ins Ausland zu verlagern oder tue das
bereits
Besuch beim belgischen Chemiekonzern
jumiko der als einziger alle Materialien
für Batterien in Europa produziert und
wo der Vorstandschef nüchtern festhält
die EU hatte bis Mitte letzten Jahres
eine ganz klare Vorreiterposition im
Bereich Elektrifizierung der Green Deal
war in vollem Schwung und was wir alle
erlebt haben wir auch als als aktiver
Teilnehmer in diesem Markt mit der
letzten Jahres hat sich sehr viel in
Richtung USA orientiert denn dann kam
der lokruf des Geldes eine präsidiale
Unterschrift 370 Milliarden US-Dollar
für Elektroautos geknüpft an eine
Bedingung die Elektroautos müssen in den
USA produziert werden oder aber in
Staaten mit denen die USA ein
Freihandelsabkommen haben
Freihandelsabkommen da war doch was ttip
vor Jahren zwischen der EU und der
US-Regierung unter Obama verhandelt
am Ende gescheitert
es rächt sich dass wir damals als Barack
Obama einen Freihandelsabkommen für
Europa und die Vereinigten Staaten von
Amerika erreichen wollte die
Bedenkenträger bei uns am Ende die Sache
zur redet haben das ist schade weil
heute könnten wir davon profitieren und
so hoffen sie in Brüssel Paris oder
Berlin jetzt auf ein Schlupfloch damit
auch Europas Unternehmen US Geld
bekommen können ohne Europa zu verlassen
auch da haben wir eine Spur die ganz gut
ist ein rohstoff-club aufzubauen um
gemeinsam widerstandsfähiger zu werden
eine Art mini-handelsabkommen ein Ausweg
vor wenigen Minuten verkündet die
eu-kommissionspräsidentin eine
grundsatzreinigung
für uns ist es wichtig dass wir unsere
Kräfte bündeln dass wir uns ergänzen und
gegenseitig unsere Unternehmen
unterstützen und das erreichen wir jetzt
es ist ein erster Etappensieg nicht mehr
auch dieses Abkommen muss schließlich
erst noch verhandelt werden
aber ein kleiner Schritt aufeinander zu
ganz aktuell noch reingekommen das Thema
dürfte die Wirtschaft heute auch bei
ihrem Jahresgespräch mit dem
Regierungschef in Deutschland bewegt
haben Hanna dazu hast du jetzt mehr
jedenfalls hatten die vier großen
Wirtschaftsverbände beim Gespräch
mit lange
Problemen im Gepäck und außerdem ganz
konkrete Forderungen an die
Bundesregierung Frank Bethmann welche
Anliegen haben industriehandwerk und
Unternehmen genau und was hat das
Treffen gebracht naja aus ihrer Sicht
muss vieles besser werden und so haben
die vier Spitzen Funktionäre das
alljährliche kanzlergespräch für die
Forderung nach dringend notwendigen
Reformen genutzt von neuen
deutschlandtempo wie es Scholz immer so
gerne nennt würden die Unternehmen
beispielsweise bislang wenig spüren
Deutschland muss wieder schneller werden
wir müssen einfacher werden wir müssen
wieder besser werden die
Entbürokratisierung wir auch wirken uns
in Vorschriften in drei und vierfach
Kontrollen für einen und dasselbe Thema
dort haben wir einen Reformstau neben
der ausufernden Bürokratie also standen
vor allem die im internationalen
Vergleich viel zu hohen Energiepreise
und der Fachkräftemangel ganz oben auf
der Liste der größten Sorgen Scholz
begegnete den Problem heute mit jeder
Menge Optimismus der klimaneutrale Umbau
von Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft würde
das Land voranbringen siehe Deutschland
vor einer Phase großen Wachstums so ganz
wollte der DAX heute allerdings in
diesem jubelreiten nicht mit einstimmen
Gegenteil mit über 200 Punkten im Minus
gab es zum Wochenschluss noch mal einen
kräftigen Dämpfer
vielen Dank Frank für deine Einschätzung
die Deutsche Post und die Gewerkschaft
Verdi verhandeln seit heute wieder
nachdem sich die Verdi Mitglieder zuvor
in einer Uhr Abstimmung gegen das
bisherige Angebot der Arbeitgeber und
für unbefristete Streiks ausgesprochen
hatten die Tarifverhandlungen für die
rund 160.000 Beschäftigten waren Mitte
Februar in der dritten Runde gescheitert
wer die fordert unter anderem 15% mehr
Gehalt das weiß die Post als
unrealistisch zurück sollte es bei den
aktuellen Verhandlungen erneut keine
Einigung geben könnte schon bald ein
unbefristeter Arbeitskampf beginnen
obwohl in Deutschland hunderttausende
Wohnungen fehlen ist die Zahl der
Baugenehmigungen 2022 gesunken konkret
wurden laut Statistischem Bundesamt
letztes Jahr
354.400 Wohnungen genehmigt das sind
6,9% weniger als im Vorjahr und der
niedrigste Stand seit 2018 besonders
groß war der Rückgang der
Baugenehmigungen bei Einfamilienhäusern
mit fast 17 Prozent Grund dafür sein
unter anderem die hohen Kosten für
Baumaterialien der Fachkräftemangel und
gestiegene Zinsen
die US-amerikanische Skifahrerin Micaela
shiffrin hat den bisherigen Rekord von
86 weltcup-siegen eingestellt
beschwerischen Ohren triumphierte die
27-Jährige beim Riesenslalom Weltcup und
zieht damit gleich mit dem Schweden
Ingmar stehen mag der die besten Marke
vor 34 Jahren aufgestellt hatte und
schon an diesem Samstag könnte shiffrin
die alleinige Rekordhalterin werden
sollte sie den Slalom Wettbewerb
gewinnen
verneigt man sich wirklich mit dieser
Ausnahme Karriere beenden wir diesen
Freitag im heute journal und danken
herzlich für Ihr Interesse und auch der
Hinweis auf unser heute journal Update
gegen 23:30 Uhr mit nazanieren von uns
allen auch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hinter den Kameras ein angenehmer Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend herzlich willkommen zum
Wetter das ja im Moment sehr turbulent
ist im Moment überquert uns dieses
kleine Sturmtief Dietel mit Sturm und
Schnee ab morgen macht sich so ein
kleines zwischenhochbreit und dann haben
wir mal einen Tag zum Durchatmen wir
schauen aber jetzt genauer auf die Nacht
schon heute Abend gibt es Sturmböen im
Süden und in der Mitte Orkanböen in den
Bergen im nachtverlauf lässt der Wind
jetzt von Westen mehr und mehr
nachgedreht aber auf nördliche Richtung
das bedeutet es wird kühler und so geht
schon jetzt der Regen im Norden und im
Westen in Schnee über das ganze
verlagert sich in der Nacht dann
ostwärts und in einem breiten Streifen
von Nordrhein-Westfalen bis nach
Brandenburg also über die nördliche
Mitte Deutschlands da schneit es kräftig
Teil 10 cm bis ins Flachland in
Berglagen auch bis 15 cm mit
Schneeverwehungen ja und vor allem im
Nordwesten wo ist ja dann im
nachtverlauf aufhört zu schneiden da
kann es richtig glatt werden
Temperaturen bis minus vier Grad oh
frostfrei ist generell heute Nacht nur
am Oberrhein morgen gibt es dann den
letzten Schnee in den östlichen Regionen
das wird nicht mehr allzu viel sein nur
an den Alpen kommen noch mal ein
bisschen was zusammen nachmittags zieht
es dann ab in den Norden kommt eine
schauerlinie mit Regen Schnee und
Graupel aber ansonsten ist der Tag meist
trocken mit größeren sonnenanteilen und
die Temperaturen die gleichen sich jetzt
an die Luftmassengrenze hat sich
abgebaut ein Grad in den östlichen
Berglagen und sieben Grad am Rhein am
Sonntag da reicht uns neue Schnee und
Regen von West nach Ost am Montag
erreicht uns ein neues Sturmtief mit
einem kurzen Frühlingstag im Südwesten
und viel Regen am Dienstag aber schon
wieder kühler Wind und Regen ist auch da
dabei also es bleibt einiges los beim
Wetter das war es von uns tschüss